ABOUT A GUY THAT IS SO
SAVE! OFFSIDE.
A COUPLE OF BRU
RANGERS TURNOVER.
HALL WITH A HIT ON SLINDGREN, J.
>> Joe: IT'S BEEN ALL RANGERS
PAIRS.
RANGERS AND STROEM.
BEAUTIFUL SETUP FROM PANARIN
FROM BEHIND THE NET.
AND THEN HERE'S THEOR CHARL
AND
ICING.
>> Joe: THERE'S THE ATTEMPTED
GOALTENDER WHO IS TRYING TO FIND
AcAI INVOLVEMENT
FINDS IT IN
CRAIG ES TO AN  LONG TIME  BLOC.
WITH THE
HE MOVES IN.
SAVE Joe: SEE IF KREIDER GOES
RAMSEY.
>> I GUESS IT'S CLEAR.
.
IT'S OKAY.
HERE WE GO IN THE SPEED.
SCORES!
WOW!
>> YOU NORMA Sam: PASTRNAK IS U!
NOTHING FANCY BY WRISTER. WE GO?
>> YES, FOR THE BOSTONHALL.
SAVE!
>> TWO GOALS FOR BOSTON AND
SCORED OVER KREIDER IS UP TO
TRY TO W THAT WAS
INTENTIONAL.
>> I ROUNDSHESTERKIN. CHYTIL W
GAME.
>> WHAT A SAVES DOWN.
THE SAVE BY SHESTERKIN. ATTEMPT.